[Música]
[Aplausos]
quando olhamos para o folclorista na
maioria de vocês pensa que é chegar lá
em cima não gostava de madeira e dar
medo e bud levamos para é que o que é o
folclore enquanto dança e não enquanto
na grafia
se falarmos na verdadeira essência do
folclore estamos a falar no estudo do
povo
ou seja estamos a transportar de
terminava a janela temporal para aquilo
as nossas apresentações e aquilo que nós
representamos
começamos aqui precisamente com as
salinas vê vinícius simples tinha sangue
mas muitos desconhecem mas é
precisamente com a indústria conserveira
era clipe nicho começa a ganhar a alma
esta altura com muita gente vai pro
peniche e christi começa a ser conhecido
falamos da conserva pelo sal e da
salmoura dizem os escritores dos finais
do século 19 e início do século 20 até
um caminho antes que enquanto em outros
portos de pesca não era assim tão
abundante do país pune se espelhava vias
brilhar o peixe nas águas envolventes do
porto com início então isso permitiu que
a indústria conserveira era desenvolver
se aqui mas esta indústria não se
conseguia desenvolver porque não haviam
não houve uma comunicação não havia
estradas então só a partir de
essencialmente dos anos 20 por aí se
começam a criar vias de comunicação que
permitiram esta inovação e esta
exportação buscavam de peniche e que
consigamos dar resposta àquilo que era
buscar para depois enviar para o
exterior tendo em conta isso também
evoluiu pois a indústria conserveira é
que vai ser o foco central do
desenvolvimento da cidade polícia tendo
em conta isto
em para iniciantes é de todas as partes
do país de outros portos é vemos que
polícia
nesta época é um dos principais portos
do país
é o centro do país eu costumo dizer aos
meus amigos que já conhecem
michel centro do mundo temos que
acreditar do nós somos e então vem gente
vindos de viana do castelo gent é lille
da figueira da foz
inclusive a nazaré sempre que via
formando nazaré havia imigrações
proponente porque é impune se havia
sempre o país e tirando os períodos de
defeso
havia sempre essa grande riqueza nas
águas envolvente e atento pois também do
algarve vieram gente para o início
fazendo a ponte entre que o que é a
janela temporal que representamos e
concretamente é que o que nós mostramos
que temos aqui
este ano uma aposta por parte do
município é naquilo que são as nossas
residente etárias e mostrando isso nós
através do trás da mudança da forma de
nos comportarmos tentamos ajustar essa
janela temporal para os dias de hoje
em relação ao investimento é o
divertimento estava quase sempre para o
lulismo com os atos religiosos
o povo era bastante religioso e que
temos uma imagem que mostra claramente
aquilo que é a igreja de são pedro ao
fundo ea ribeira velha com o trabalho do
dos barcos dizia carvalho figueira que
nem o maior empregador fazia antever os
pescadores que assim que eu sentia que o
mar estava um papel que corriam polícia
baixo em deus no barco e iam buscar para
sustentar a família com esses atos
religiosos chamemos lhe assim os mais
importantes eram os filhos temos do
santuário nossa senhora dos remédios que
serve cerca de 25 sírios que são os
filhos não são mais romarias com
determinada a devolução algum santo e
que associava isso a via
um agradecimento e então havia festa era
aqui que tenhamos as maiores
manifestações folclóricas início do
folclore do ponto de vista já daquilo
que nós transportamos para para palco
mas da atividade lúdica da coisa
chamemos lhe assim é comum
nós até falarmos com os mais idosos
enquanto os anos participo técnicas de
nosso país deixando sair à noite
transportando pra época as mulheres
principalmente saiu de casa com a mãe
como madrinha com o irmão mais velho é e
foi nós fazemos o trabalho de recolha
junto dos mais idosos e as mais idosas
irmão nunca dançavam porque meu pai não
deixava dilma cinco novos a música casa
os u2 que usa droga pronto por realmente
a sociedade não era a sociedade que
temos hoje aqui transportanto claramente
para que o que representamos
temos várias particularidades é impune
se principalmente até a nível da dança
na maioria são bairros roda mas enquanto
por exemplo nota
a maioria das pessoas num bairro não se
juntava nós aqui também éramos muito à
frente
os passos já tocavam quando dançavam
algumas particularidades do nosso povo
chance
tendo em conta estas influências nós
conseguimos ver em peniche depois com os
barcos dos pescadores e das pessoas que
vinham de fora é para trabalhar vários
hábitos vários linguajar várias maneiras
de ser essa influência por exemplo aqui
nós vemos o cantinho um parceiro fiel e
enquanto vimos aquela senhora que vem da
fonte que é uma senhora da nazaré pelo
por dodô chão por exemplo ainda há aqui
há tempos me davam chamava atenção minha
experiência e puxá lo encontrado
nós víamos as nazarenas propunham o
chapéu em bico ainda hoje falamos com os
mais idosos quando estamos a fazer esse
trabalho de escolha então desenhar tal
sentiu até lá vive humanas arena elas
nas arenas
era um gente já muito à frente da época
enquanto os autores que viu a mulher do
político muito séria
magrinha foi assim com bigode que
chegavam a uma janela que tenham algo
para lá por casa dizer o quê
a minha filha as novas arenas não eram
me acho que já traziam outra outra
abertura portanto ser v
vivia uma mulher da nazaré era tipo de
carga teve humanas arena era assim
caminha para o lulismo entre culturas
depois as mulheres da murtosa que vieram
princípio para poder trabalhar
trazem também os seus usos e costumes e
que vai também influenciar a forma de se
comportarem e das pessoas também
trajarem trabalharem porque depois de
cada por pesca traziam as suas
embarcações e quando chegavam a peniche
obviamente que faziam esta aculturação
se formos qual garfo vamos já ter estas
figuras figuras bizarras ainda os
invernos de simples xixi do uso de um
capote na mulher que resguardava que
percebi o local e viu a mulher já tinha
outro tipo de cacto não só no luto mas
por outras por outras ocasiões
esta gente vai fazer um carro a
diversidade de peniche tal como nós hoje
temos e conhecemos sendo a algar
tenhamos a proximidade com o mar
mediterrâneo temos também as influências
dos fenícios que se julga ser influência
dos fenícios as vendas de euros
as grandes bills que se espalham de
norte a sul do país e que vão ter grande
importância em três pontos do país vila
do conde
nice e algarve embora atualmente só a 12
pontos do país que tem maior trabalho e
renda que é precisamente o do corpo e
peniche em 1883 que a escola a dona
maria pia é inaugurada e aí temos outra
vertente das rendas de bilros já
anteriormente 1.500 e qualquer coisa as
vendas ganham prêmios e internacionais
portanto não é uma coisa agora mas é
nesta época que a dona maria augusta
bordalo pinheiro vai desenvolver as
rendas de bilros de peniche e que
viramos uma página na história
a licença também ao nível veio na grafia
porque a este nível é também vai criar
desenhos novos e vai influenciar até
chegarmos aqui o que é
as da mulher no início temos aqui a
mostra do traço da polícia mostra
nacional do traje popular português até
aos dias de hoje
ainda vemos algumas pessoas que mantêm
esta identidade mas o trás da mulher
devemos falar várias vertentes do trás
mas este era mais comum que era uma das
pessoas que usavam no seu dia a dia o
lenço na cabeça o avental melhor o
domingo mais usado durante a semana o
próprio e para o trabalho e um chapéu
o chapéu que acompanhava pessoa durante
a sua vida e que gera muitas das vezes
uma morte e dos afetos família se
lembravam ser embalados no shell da avó
é porque passava de geração em geração
portanto o chelsea também com este valor
sentimental apresentando aquilo que são
os traços de peniche
nada melhor que vos mostrar ao vivo
aquilo que era o trajeto início ao longo
de todo este trabalho de recolha às
vezes perguntam então tu quer que o
fatos no trabalho entrevistas velhinhas
não entrevistas só velhinhas meio
ambiente
assim fazemos enquanto o grupo um
trabalho que nos permita mostrar
realmente e transpor ser global
aqui eu quero o traje da mulher polícia
à época como já expliquei mesmo lenço ao
o ao chão e depois ao avental enquanto
no homem mais simples uma camisa de
quadrados enquanto na antiguidade havia
traz mais alinhados depois começou a ver
a evolução e até há bem pouco tempo
imploravam o xadrez portanto o trás do
homem e mulher de peniche a nivel do
divertimento nós tenhamos divertimentos
muitos impulso desde o pífaro a caninha
a ou até as cordas o cordão surge porque
início já junto aos anos 40 e vai
importar de italia e acusava um ao ver
vir pra cá informou depois entretanto o
primeiro rancho dos pescadores e
rendeiras mas na antiguidade à época que
nós representamos
era tudo muito mais arcaicos e aqui
podemos chamar assim
portanto as nossas músicas não era mais
que começa cortes enquanto homens e
mulheres se juntavam havia uma grande
simples
no povo e era forma simples que as
pessoas se divertiam
portanto como vem
esta simplicidade também da parte da
música de um de peniche
nós vivemos
vivemos num país muito pobre vivemos
vivemos num país do pé descalço
nós só a partir de 1910
temos a primeira fábrica de conservas
com olhos é imponente e depois em 1912
quando a fábrica do fialho abra este
começa a andar para a frente porque até
então vivemos desde os romanos ainda na
na salga e é comum
nós ouvimos até as pessoas dizem eu
nunca me divertir toda a vida trabalhei
mas o que é certo é que as pessoas
acabavam por ter tempo para se divertir
e portanto associando a música à dança
vamos transpor ser pra quê nos curtos
segundos
aquilo que era um divertimento alguém
alguém que era o dia dos agravos
ou seja o link as pessoas davam graças
pela vida que tinham e que a juntar o
útil ao agradável e até aproveitavam
para os manics que era assim que surgiu
porque era a forma dos homens que verei
ganhar a mulher era comum as notas
dirani mais sobre os lapsos que deus não
vai lhe deixar vem dançar porque depois
casavam com maioria pobre
por isso esteriótipos criaram então a
dança tradicional que era também
normalmente modas droga e depois é a
garrafa aparelho
como vem a simplicidade modas de rodas
impus que toda a gente chegava aos
terreiros e pudesse lançar o movimento
também as músicas tenham influência das
várias regiões que nos visitaram até aos
dias de hoje e também então apresentação
daquilo que é a dança como e mais ainda
afinal deixarmos precisamente essa ideia
do que o foco agora é uma coisa muito
séria e que só com muito trabalho e com
muita persistência conseguimos fazer um
trabalho assim às vezes ouvimos falar
até lá na assembleia da república os
deputados dizem que isto é tudo falso
hora mas que não sabem verdadeiramente a
aplicação do termo folclore o folclore
estuda um povo uma comunidade numa
terminava janela temporal neste caso é
que nós definimos finais do século 19 e
início do século 20
e é com muito orgulho que mostramos fora
de peniche até além fronteiras porque em
janeiro iremos até a espanha e nos
festivais internacionais onde o rancho
folclórico geral estão também
participado que vamos um pouco das
nossas gentes um pouco das nossas
tradições e um pouco da nossa imagem de
marca é bom que os que cá vivem também
saibam valorizar este trabalho
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]